eine karte es ist auch toll
warum kommt ihr doch da bitteschön
extreme jedoch schon sehr hart vor kraus
leben lang rat sitzt der karte
hallo meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge von
games zusammen mit dem was verliere
verlor so aufgefallen ist als wir wir
haben weiter wo könnten diese fackel
sein
ich habe noch einen letzten fackel im
inventar ich weiß nicht ohne ohne witz
ich weiß nicht wie lange das schon drin
ist vielleicht auch schon der vorletzte
folgen der letzten folge der gommer
aufgenommen da kann er nicht mit
inventar gucken wir fragen und die ganze
zeit nur wo ist die redstone fackel
comedy ist da oben raus gefallen da oben
damit du da und wenn ihr einfach
bekommen und da ich mir dann meine ganze
weiß ich habe meine ganze inventar
leiste runden mit diesen ganzen
schwertern voll gehabt deswegen war die
einfach oben in dem inventar dollar
sehen hier nicht gesehen deswegen wird
mir da die red zum fackel drauf und dann
können wir jetzt ganz normal weiter
springen genau wir haben dadurch halt
ein schalter mehr den wir eventuell
später brauchen denn in meiner aufnahme
hat man schon spätere aufnahme räume
gesehen da stand etwas von irgendwie
drei lämmer braucht man ja und ja und ja
schon meine aufnahme hier bin ich
schonmal ich ich wäre das schön wir
abgeschossen
vor der aufnahme ich spring daher ging
drüber und die jetzt einfach hier so
eine
das ding ist auch du hast die aufnahmen
ich bin ich bin hier zum lagerraum
wissen im lagerraum ich will das jetzt
schaffen hier
bevor ich mich da ich mich aber nicht
irgendwie was kommt danach kommt danach
von lianen dingsbums er genau der oben
kommt danach realen raum
so isch landschaft ist aber warte ich
mal hier lieber auf dich dein name
ernährt sich dem richtigen ich halte
mich einfach nicht fest ich geh jetzt
wirklich einfach zu viel
ich hasse diese leiter sprünge du hast
bestimmt wieder getreue du hast ja
irgendwie was will hingesetzt
also ich kann immer gut drüber lachen
hier bist du schon eingegangen oder das
möchte ich auch machen ich habe die
sprünge man sich probiert hier vor
aber du kannst du dir die leitern
springen ja jetzt darf ich hier noch mal
die ganzen blöden sprünge machen kann
gut mit den leitern springen du
wahrscheinlich anders du da nicht auch
in die lava fällst das nenne ich gerade
ganz so geil wie bei mir gerade beim ist
er wieder da wurde eben auch schon die
ganze zeit nehme ich bin eh wieder bei
den über die leiter sprünge schon weg
aber ich will dass man das wenn heute
hier meine rennen hier weggehen
animations- auch so keine ahnung das
werde ich die kunden diese von allen
seiten kommen würde so ein bisschen so
richtig feuer mäßig aber jetzt ist es
wirklich einfach nur so von unten
du hast viel geschafft dazwischen zeigt
aidoo ich musste er warten bis sich auf
abzubrennen bastl hallo mensch aber ich
lebe doch ich lebe doch oh gott zwar
jetzt zweieinhalb herzen hält den sprung
ist noch schwierig verschafft
der ist auch nicht der 08 spieler
vorgeschoben
naja ich hab gar nicht geschubst das ist
meine aufnahme sehen echt nicht einfach
nach hinten irgendwie ich bin einfach zu
weit an die lava bevor ich weiß ihr euch
das packe ganz dahinter dass wir uns
gegenseitig wegdrücken könnt wie in
einer ganz alten minecraft version
herunter
ja deswegen dass er sich ja gerade das
terrain kommen haftungen hier aber naja
wenn der staat da ist nix drin und kann
auf der messe ich hab' ich habe schalter
ich habe schalter jetzt müssen wir noch
hier lang also nicht jetzt wann wir
berühren uns mal herrlich komisch eben
gerade das kann ich habe aber echt nicht
geschlagen das kann man meine aufnahme
sehen
da glaube ich sehe hier ein eps von fdp
denn durch so und jetzt aha wir wollen
natürlich hier zum bus oder ja ja klar
altrip ist ja kein visum ausstellen was
steht da plate vistream s next to the
doors ich frag mal einen hier drauf
stark wenn du den normaldruck sollten
mach du das machst du das erst mal ich
komme danach durch so dass er zwei
schalter juli und jetzt was das jetzt
hier einer wiese abgeschossen oder wie
oh ja stimmt das ist natürlich dass er
jetzt haben wir den wo haben wir denn
jetzt bitte unseren check point software
schalter gedrückt auf welchen schalter
ja auf den halter hier bei den sprüngen
hier rechts
ach da jeder versteht niemand schildert
das einfach so ein holz schalter ja
immer drücken
ich sehe hier nicht mal wenn das so weil
das buch beleuchtet ist wo genau die
blöcke sind ich vielleicht jetzt einfach
mal jeden block aus einmal hoffen
da das heißt es ist jetzt quasi so die
boss challenge die wiedergabe machen
müssen
nein ich war voll weit und ich habe
übrigens in meinem video noch mal
nachgeguckt welche schwierigkeit dass
hier überhaupt sein soll
das hier ist ein zwischending zwischen
mittel und hart
achso diese hier ja dieser parcours
ich fand es aber nicht so schwer als
eigentlich also dass am anfang fand ich
echt wirklich am allerschlimmsten
allerdings immer direkt auf den anderen
block dahinten das geht nicht
hab ich gesehen war keine gute idee von
mir sondern einfach hier entlang
aber das will ich mit den lehrern also
wird da wäre darunter fällt er ist aber
schon der musik von craft erhalten
ja man das ist so gemein weil man
bekommt falschheit ich würde dir raten
bei jedem sprung stehen bleiben einmal
auf dem blog nicht in einem run durch
das geht nicht
das aber ich will dich mit den lehrern
hier ja so ich gibt den tipp darauf das
geht wunderbar auf dem blog aber dann
nicht jetzt in einem rasch durch also
nicht einmal komplett durch rennen und
dann immer springen dann beim nächsten
spiel zu schaffen nicht nur mal springe
ich lauf als fakt ich habe ich sagt
bringen vergessen einfach man so aber
mehr läuft ich glaubte auch komplett an
dich komme jetzt gerade besser springen
ist nicht so meine stärke merkt man
so habe es geschafft komplett war da ich
mache ich mal licht stimmt so hier ist
auf jeden fall leben und jeder weiß das
leben und komme zusammen immer nur etwas
gutes ergeben kann und ich spüre
deswegen auch hier ein ende der karte
aber leben erleben euch liebe leben wir
wirklich mit dem spex texture pack ich
liebe leben einfach nicht in mainz muss
cool aus dieser rannte leben dieser neue
richtig cool orion schalter und ein
schwein im sattel
ich bin ich was bei den lehrern
runtergefallen halter und nein und nein
das schafft man das schon verloren
dem ersten abkürzung hier
dazu kommen das ist es sicher auch nicht
dass das hier so zehnmillionenfach was
erwarten sie schaffen so hallo mich
wieder runter gefallen wegen die jetzt
ließ einfach mal was sie auf den
schildern steht europe exchange
very hard difficulty extreme nach
dilemma wanderreise challenge jetzt
hätte ich niemals gedacht das ist doch
schon einige dachte ich bin noch nie da
diesen komischen altar gelaufen so
bisher nicht
neben dir hier oben drauf wo ich keine
davor so dazwischen die schilder
reisetyp hinter dir challenge 7
minecraft belgien nie aus dem haus oder
in der wachau nicht eigentlich
mittlerweile wieder ich will ja schweiz
trat extreme art versteht hier hinten
first checkpoint alter wie viele
checkpoints gibt es ab weil gott wie
lange wir einfach jedoch springen wer
dachte naja ok alles kriegt das ja mal
richtig easy wir dachten wir werden euch
fertig jeder folge jetzt noch neue
checkpoints und wenn die karte schon so
viele checkpoints hat ist ein schalter
ich hab gebockt mehr als hinsetzen
allerdings ist an schalter das ist echt
traurig man das ist ja hier runter oder
muss irgendwie so an dem ding her gleich
denn es geht auch nicht doch es geht
hier unten kann man auch einfach nicht
springen ich weiß es nicht und das noch
richtig schwierige sprünge einfach mal
das ist einfach richtig schwierige
sprünge
warum kommt er doch da bitteschön
extreme einfach wie heute schon sehr
hart vor kreissägen leben lang besitzer
der karte
gleich danach kommt noch so einmalig wie
viele sprünge dass mein gott isaaks ist
ich hab noch mein einstiegspunkt der
zehn gesetzt so bin ich da gar nicht
gespart wo bist nur entlang
ich bin auch vom höllental gesponnene
muster auf die sich aus so ein blog the
video star vor gemacht hast dann muss
drauf ich komme da nicht drauf doch das
ist es
ich bin auch wieder vom vom portal hier
das ist echt die hölle hier vielleicht
liegt einfach daran dass man keins
ponton in never setzen kann
es wurde deaktiviert oder sonstwas um
machen
die konzerte finden im springen wir dann
hier überhaupt heben ich weiß ja nicht
so will es der alte mit zwei grad
die eine mega kurz die eine war echt
cool ex projekt 21
ich kann mich an gucke ich dass es echt
eine bestrafung hier wir so müssten
einen studenten partie trotz machen
damit wir ein jackpot noch durch
schaffen bring uns einfach ab ob wir in
einer folge mehr als einen checkpoint
schaffen werden noch mindestens neun
folge ihre halte ich mal probiert mich
zu den jackpot zu teleportieren aber es
geht nicht einmal wenigstens anlass war
einmal ein gamer wir wollen dass ich das
ist es wohl was machst du da und ich hab
das ist sehr guten weg zum schicken
gefunden das war der fall wo ich
darunter bin aber ich habe vor allem was
gesehen als ich davon erfuhr ist
runtergefallen bin so johann es kann
doch nicht sein ich weiß ich werde dich
gerade recht ja ich weiß wo du lange
willst du willst was dann rauskommt blog
drauf springen durch die fliege ich will
dir zeigen erste schalter
nein da muss ich jetzt einfach mal okay
aber ich mache mir das ein
einstiegspunkt ist er bringt er ähnlich
viel neues der rest wurde hinzugefügt
und bitteschön wie krank ist das denn
wenn wo mein gott das ist unmöglich das
kann man nicht schaffen um euch heute
nicht ohne spaß ich bin dort mit game
auf einen bloß den block der so 20
weitere blöcke weiter weg dahin geflogen
und schon wieder den nächsten sprung
nicht wir beraten uns beide wie wir das
jetzt machen dann sehen uns in der
nächsten folge bei was meint ihr
schreibt mal bitte wie wir hier
weitermachen sondern ob ihr bock habt
ihr auf dieses ding schreibt dass er
wird in die kommentare ob ihr wirklich
hier so eine extrem langes köln folgen
blablabla wollte uns wo wir hier einfach
mal zehn folgen mindestens einer höhle
unterwegs sind
wollt ihr das wirklich haben das ist
nicht ich will nicht zuletzt gibt es die
auch nichts grünes licht war baum
hier wird man etwas depressiv oder hölle
sagt ihr die hölle
hier muss man auch ja das recht die
hölle gefallen hat bewertung und sonst
guckt morgen bei komme wieder vorbei
haut rein